hi there welcome to this new video
series called s3 tutorial I'm Samuel and
cloud architect and evangelist working
for simply long and I'm gonna be touring
you with different s3 features and
technical details in this section so
what are we gonna learn we're gonna
learn about what is cloud storage in
general and then the types of storage
available in general in the cloud and
how things were before anybody adopted
using s3 that's something are we gonna
learn and then we're gonna immediately
dive into what is s3 and then the
benefits of using s3 over other storage
and then we're gonna do couple of labs
or console walkthroughs about what is
object and how to add an object
what is bucket how to create a bucket
stuff like that and then we're gonna
talk about how Amazon s3 generally works
now it comes with a lot of features it
comes with a lot of promise how does
this all work
how does Amazon able to keep up with the
promise we're gonna talk about that and
then we will talk about some features
add-on features that comes along with
Amazon s3 so what is cloud storage in
general cloud storage is a service that
provides web services where we can store
our data and not only that that data can
be easily accessed and the data can be
easily backed up everything over the
Internet in short if you could store
your data if you could access the data
if you could backup your data
everything you do through the internet
then that's a good definition for cloud
storage and additional definitions are
in cloud storage we only pay for what we
use you know no commitment no
proportioning is you know pay-as-you-go
type subscription and the best part is
we pay on a monthly basis you know we
don't rent a hardware for the year or we
don't give commitment for the whole year
it's pay-as-you-go and pay on a monthly
basis and these cloud storages are very
reliable meaning once you put the data
in it it's never gonna get lost and
these cloud storages are scalable
assuming I have a requirement to store
hundred times of what
actual data sizes and I want it now it's
available in the cloud and these
storages are secure as well because
we're talking about data data virginity
they need to be secured and Amazon
provides tools and technologies through
which we can secure our data and these
are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage in
general so s3 is cloud storage in AWS
and then we have elastic block store now
elastic block store is actually the SSD
hard drives that gets attached to our
ec2 instance you know it's like the C
Drive it's like the D Drive it's like
the E Drive that gets attached to our
instances now EFS is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but it differs from EBS in a way
that EBS can be accessed only by the
system that's attached to it meaning the
e volumes and the D volumes we spoke
about they can be accessed only if there
is an instance connected to it but these
EFS are actually shared file systems
elastic file system all right there are
shared systems they can be accessed by
multiple systems they can be accessed
from inside the Amazon environment it
can be accessed from on premises
equipment as well the glacier is
actually the archiving solution in the
cloud if you want to dump a data and try
to keep them in the low cost as possible
then glacier is the product we should be
using and then we have storage gateway
if I want to safely move my data from my
local environment to the cloud and with
almond and also want to keep a copy of
the data locally so users locally can
access them and in a cloud users or
Internet users can access the data from
the cloud if that's your requirement
then storage gateway is the one we would
be choosing and then we have snowballs
snowball is really an data import and
export system but it is actually an
Hardware that gets shipped to our
premises where we can copy a data into
it and then ship it back to Amazon and
Amazon would copy the data into whatever
destination would give them in our
account and if the data is
really huge then I can call for a
snowmobile which is actually a data
center on a truck where Amazon would
send me an truck loaded with the data
center as you see that has compute
capacity lots and lots of storage
capacity an electricity AC and lot more
and so they get come parked near our
data center and cables run into our data
center we can copy data into it send it
back to Amazon and they would copy it to
our account and whatever storage that we
advise them so if the data is really
really huge then I would be calling snow
mobiles no mobile is not available in
all the regions all right let's take
this example how things were before s3
was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and one of them is finding it very
difficult to sort of manage all the data
in the organization well if the data is
small it can be easily managed but as
company grow and we are living in an era
where data is everything we want data to
back up every idea we want data to back
up every proof of concept that we
provide so data is everything so this
era is all about collecting data
analyzing them and saving you know not
losing a logs you know saving them
analyzing stuff like that so coming back
to a discussion here one person finds it
very difficult to store and manage all
the data that they have so some of the
data that this person is having problem
storing is data stat application used to
running and then a data that gets sent
to the customers and data is that the
websites required the data there are
because of the email backups and lot
more are the storages that an enterprise
can have and this person is having
problem backing up all those data and
even if we think of increasing the local
storage capacity that's going to cost a
fortune and few things that make it
sometimes impossible to increase the
storage capacity in-house is you know we
will have to go and pay heavy to buy
hardware and software to run these
storages and we
need to hire a team of experts for
maintaining them the hardware and the
software and anytime if there is a
dynamic increase in the storage capacity
the on-premises or in-house hardware's
won't be able to scale and data security
data security is very costly when it
comes to building our own storage and
without in-house and adding data
security on top of it so the other guy
in the conversation was sort of quietly
listening everything the manager was
saying and then he slowly introduced him
to s3 because he knew that all the
problem that this manager was worried
about can be solved to yesterday in
other words all the scalability all the
data security all the not being able to
provision hardware and software
components are all available with s3 so
that actually brings us to the
discussion about what s3 is s3 is simple
storage service it actually provides an
object storage service let me talk to
you about object and block storage
object storage is where you can store
things in the drive alright you can't
install anything in it and this object
storage can be accessed directly from
the Internet
whereas block storage is something that
needs to be attached to an instance and
we can't directly access it but we can
install software in it so that's
high-level difference between object
storage and block storage and s3 is an
object storage what does that mean we
can store data from the internet we can
retrieve from the internet but we can't
install anything in s3 all right so so
s3 is an object-based storage and it's
it's really built for storing and
recovering or retrieving any amount of
data or information from anywhere in the
Internet few other things you need to
know about s3 is that the zest tree is
accessible through the web interface the
storage one type of accessing or one way
of accessing yesterday is by dragging
dropping content into it and another way
of retrieving data from s3 is go to a
browser click on download that's going
to let you download any content and the
data can be 5 terabytes in size now
we're talking about one
while you can have hundreds or thousands
of files like that one file can be as
big as five terabytes in size and s3 is
basically designed for developers where
they can push logs into s3 or try blocks
anytime they want instead of storing
locally or in the server they can use s3
as code repositories you know where they
can save the code and have the
applications read the code from there
and a lot more if they want to safely
share the code with another person with
a lot of encryption and security added
on top of it that's possible as well so
there are a few things about s3 and on
top of all this s3 provides 11-9
durability and 4:9 availability meaning
durability is if I store the data will
it get lost Amazon is like no it's not
gonna get lost you're gonna have the
data out because we provide 11-9
durability for the data and availability
is if you want the data now will you be
able to show it Amazon is like yes we
will be able to show it we have 99.99%
availability and when you request the
data we will be able to show the data to
you all right so let's talk about the
benefits of s/3 s/3 is durable as we saw
it provides levan line durability s3 is
low cost out of all the storage options
in Amazon s3 is the cheapest and s3 is
very scalable like we were saying that
there's no required to pre provision
storage capacity you know if you need
more go ahead and use more if you need
even more go ahead and use even more and
once you're done some data needs to be
removed just remove the data so that
particular month you would be paying
less so it's very scalable in nature and
it's very available as well s3 isn't
regional service you know it's not based
on one availability zone so one
availability zone going down with an
Amazon the whole availability going down
it's not gonna affect your ability to
access s3 storage an s3 is secure a lot
of security features like bucket policy
a lot of security features like
encryption and then MFA authentication
are possible with s3 that actually adds
a very good security layer on top of the
data that we have stored in s3 and not
only that this s3
is very flexible in terms of cost
flexible in terms of where I want to
store the data in terms of cost there
are a lot of pricing tiers with an s3 s3
itself is a cheap service now within
that we have lot of pricing tiers
depending on the durability if so I can
always choose to put data on a different
storage tier or storage option in s3
we're going to talk about it as you
stick along and in terms of flexibility
in the region I can always choose any of
the region available in the console or
in the s3 console to put my data - there
is no restrictions on where I can or
cannot put the data in the cloud as long
as there are regions available for me to
move the data - and data transferring
with s3 is very simple all I have to do
is browse to the bucket upload the data
and the data gets uploaded and we can
also upload data using CLI commands are
very similar to Linux commands are very
similar to what we would use in the run
command prompt in Windows and what we
would use in the run command prompt in
the powershell alright let's talk about
a basic building block of s3 which is
bucket and objects now what's a bucket
what's an object object is the actual
data and bucket is the folder where the
objects get stored let me give you a new
definition for objects so object is the
actual data plus some information that
reference the data like is it an JPEG
file the name of the file and at what
time it was added to so they're called
metadata
all right so object is actually data
plus metadata and bucket is actually a
container that receives the data and
safely stores in it and when we add a
data in a bucket Amazon s3 creates an
unique version ID and allocates it to
the object so we can easily identify it
at a later point let me show you a quick
lab on s3
alright I'm in the SD console if you're
wondering how I reached here go to
services under storage and s3 is right
here and let's create a bucket called
simply lot now the bucket names will
have to be unique so I really doubt if
simply learn will be available let's
let's check it anywhere
alright it doesn't seem to be available
so let me pick another name or let's
call it simply lawn dot
Samuel car and I'm gonna put this in by
or I can choose out again let me choose
Oregon Oregon yes let me choose Oregon
and let me create a bucket sure enough a
bucket got created let me applaud an
object into the bucket and you know
these objects can be as big as five
terabytes we talked about it right all
right let me upload an object all right
so that's my object so you get the
relation right here's my bucket all
right here's my bucket and within that
is my object now object is the action
file plus what type of file it is and
then and then the size of the file the
date in which it got added and the
storage class it is in at the moment so
if you have to access it I can simply
access it through the internet so let's
talk about how does this s3 bucket work
anyway
all right so how does it work a user
creates a bucket they will specify the
region in which the bucket should be
deployed we had an option we could have
chosen to deploy in all the regions
Amazon provides s3 service you know beat
not Virginia beat Mumbai beat Tokyo beat
City beat Oregon and we choose Oregon to
be the destination region where we want
to create a bucket and save our data
there and when we upload data into the
bucket we can specify three types of
storage classes in our case we pick the
default which was s3 standard as we saw
on the object data it was on s3 standard
so that's the basic thing later once the
object gets added we can always add
bucket policies you know policies define
who access it and who should not access
it what can they access are we gonna
allow users only to read or to read
right as well stuff like that so that's
bucket policy we're defining the life
cycle or the lifespan of the data in the
s3 bucket now over the time do you want
the data to automatically move to a
different storage tier and at any point
do you want to sort of expire the data
you know get the data flushed out of
your account automatically and those
things can be configured in lifecycle
policies and version control is creating
multiple versions if you're gonna use s3
for a code repository creating multiple
versions let's say if you want to roll
back to whatever you had before a month
how we're gonna do it if you kept
updating the file and never - coercion
of it so version control helps us to
keep different versions and it helps us
to roll back to the older version
anytime there is a need so let's talk
about the different storage classes in
s3 the different storage classes in s3
begins with s3 standard now this is the
default and it's very suitable for use
cases where you need less or low latency
for example if you want to access the
data of students attendance you would
retrieve them very quickly as much as
possible so that's a good use case to
store data in s3 let's understand the
different storage classes and Amazon s3
now let's take a school for example and
the the different data is present in a
school and the features of those data
are validity of the data all right so
let's take this example and there are
different storage options in s3
let's take s3 standard for example and
what would be the actual candidate data
that can be stored in s3 standard let's
talk about that so s3 standard in
general is suitable for a use cases
where the latency should be very low and
in here the good example or the good
candidate file that can be stored in s3
is a data that needs to be frequently
accessed and that needs to be a try
quickly something like students
attendance report or students attendance
sheet which we access daily and then it
needs to be retrieved immediately as in
when we need it the other type of
storage tier in esterday is infrequent
access or infrequent data access just
like the name says the use case for that
is less frequently accessed data I mean
the candidate data that should go in
infrequent access data is a student's
academic record you know which we don't
need access on a daily basis but if
there is a requirement we might want to
go and look at it and that's gonna be
quick so it's not a data that we would
access on a daily basis but it's a data
that needs to show up on your screen
real quick and the third option is
Amazon glacier now glacier is really an
archival solution in the cloud so for
archives high performance is not a
requirement so let's talk about some
candidate data that can go into archives
something like students admission fee
and it's not critical also now anytime
if you want to look at the data you can
always wait to drive the data so in
other words you know put it in the
archive and retrieving from the archival
takes time so students old record are a
good candidate to be put in the archives
the other options are one's own I a
storage class where the data is in
frequently accessed and the data is
stored in an single availability zone
for example now by default Amazon stores
data in multiple availability zones and
there is a charge for that now it's not
an option but the charge includes
storing data in multiple availability
zones but if your data requirement is
you want to keep the charges in a low
even further you can choose a one so on
I a storage class where it stores data
in one availability zone and the
candidate data that can go in one zone
infrequent access is student's report
card and the other option with Amazon s3
is standard reduce redundancy storage it
is suitable for cases where the data is
not critical and the data can be
reproduced
for example you know take a copy of the
library book take a copy of the PDF
library book for example now we would
have a source PDF and we would make
copies of it and then we make it
available for the readers to read the
other option in s3 is reduced redundancy
storage here the use case is data that's
not critical and a data can be
reproduced quickly for example a books
and the library are not that critical
and we always have a copy after book
we're talking about PDF so if the
customer-facing or the student facing
book gets deleted
I can always copy the same PDF put it in
at the destination folder and make it
available for the users to read that
would be a very good use case for reduce
redundancy storage
all right let's summarize everything
that we learned about different storage
options in s3 so s3 standard it's for
frequently accessed data it's the
default storage if you don't mention
anything the data gets stored an s3
standard it can be used for cloud
applications you know content
distribution gaming applications big
data analytic dynamic websites they are
a very good used case for s3 standard
frequently accessed data the other one
on the contrary is s3 standard in
frequently accessed data just like the
name says the use case is this is good
for data that will be less frequently
accessed and and then the use case are
it's good for backups it's good for
disaster recovery and it's good for
lifelong storage of data glacier on the
other hand is very suitable for
archiving data which is in frequently
accessed and the Walt lock feature is
the security feature of the glacier that
also provides a long-term data storage
in the cloud this is the lowest storage
to your with an s3 the other options are
one's own infrequent access storage
class just like the name says it's
infrequently accessed and it is stored
in just one availability zone and use
cases are any data that doesn't require
any high level of security can be stored
here
in one's own v storage here is reduce
redundancy storage this is good for data
that's frequently accessed it's good for
data that is non-critical and that can
be reproduced if it gets lost and reduce
redundancy storage or RS is an highly
available solution designed for sharing
or storing data that can be reproduced
quickly
alright let's compare and contrast a
couple of other features that are
available in s3 for example durability
availability SSL support first bike
latency and lifecycle management so in
standard the durability is 11:9
durability it's the same for standard
standard ia
one zone I a glacier except for reduce
redundancy the durability is 11-9 and
availability of all the storage classes
is all the same except for one zone ie
where the availability zone is 99.5
percentage all of these products are
bought SSL connection and the first byte
latency of these products are most of
them provide access with millisecond
latency except for glacier it provides a
travel time of couple of minutes to a
maximum of hours and all of them can be
used for a lifecycle management you know
moving data from one storage tier to
another storage here that's possible
with all of these storage options all
right now that we've understood the
different types of storage options
available on s3 let's talk about some of
the features that are available on s3
lifecycle management
now lifecycle management is a service
that helps us to define a set of rules
that can be applied to an object or to
the bucket itself life cycle is actually
moving the data from one storage to do
another storage tier and finally
expiring it and and completing the
lifecycle of the object with lifecycle
management we can manage and store our
objects in a very cost-effective way it
has two features basically transition
actions
and exploration actions let's talk about
transition actions with transition
action we can choose to move the objects
or move the data from one storage class
to another storage class what lifecycle
management we can configure s3 to move
our data from one storage class to
another storage class at a defined time
interval or at a defined schedule let's
talk about transition actions in more
detail let's say we have our data in s3
at the moment and we haven't used the
data or quite some time and it's that's
how it's gonna be for the rest of the
time so that data is a very good
candidate to move to the infrequent axis
because s3 standard is a bit costlier
and s3 infrequent access is a bit
cheaper than s3 standard so the kind of
usage sort of fits very well for moving
that data into infrequent access so
using life cycle transition or life
cycle management I can move the data to
s3 infrequent access after 30 days and
let's say that the data stayed in
infrequent access for 30 more days and
then now I realize that nobody is
looking into the data so I can find an
appropriate storage here for that
particular data again and I can move it
to that particular storage tier which is
glacier so in this case after 30 days or
in a total of 60 days from the time the
data got created the data can be moved
to glacier and what does this really
help us with the lifecycle management
help us to automatically migrate our
data from one storage cost to another
storage cost and by that it really helps
us to save the storage cost lifecycle
management can also help us with object
exploration meaning deleting the object
or flushing it out after a certain
amount of time let's say that our
compliance requirement requires that we
keep the data for seven years and we
have like thousands and thousands of
data like that it would be humanly
impossible to check all those or keep
track of all the dates and you know when
they need to be deleted stuff like that
but with lifecycle management it is very
much possible I can simply create a data
and setup lifecycle management for the
data to expire after seven
years and exactly after seven years the
data is gonna expire meaning it's going
to be deleted automatically from the
account all right let me show you a lab
on lifecycle management and let me
explain to you how will it's actually
done so I'm into the bucket that we have
created and here's our data into the
bucket I assume we have thousands and
thousands of data in the bucket and that
requires to be put in a different
storage tier over time and that requires
to be expired after seven years let's
say so the way I would create a
lifecycle management is go to management
from inside the bucket and click on
lifecycle and then add and lifecycle
rule
just give it a name name like expire so
all the objects that's present in this
bucket
meaning the current version of it set a
transition for it the transition is at
the moment they are in s3 so here I
would like to put them in infrequent
access after 30 days and then after it's
been an infrequent access for 30 days I
would like to move it to Glacier all
right plus 30 days so how do you read it
so for the first 30 days it's gonna be
in Glacier so how do we actually read it
after I put the data in s3 the data is
gonna get moved to standard ia and then
it's gonna stay in standard I here and
after 60 days from the date Rea ssin
it's gonna get moved to Glacier so on
the 31st day is gonna move to standard
ie on the sixty-first day it's gonna
move to Glacier let's say if I want to
sort of delete the data if I want the
data to get deleted automatically after
seven years you know being in a glacier
how do I go about doing it let me open
up a code calculator 365 into seven
that's two thousand five hundred fifty
five days right after that the data is
gonna get deleted pretty much I have
created a life cycle so after on the
31st day it's gonna get moved to
infrequent axes and on the sixty-first
day glacier and after seven years is
over any data that I put in the bucket
it's gonna get deleted alright let's
talk about bucket policies bucket
policies are some uh permission files
that we can attach to
a bucket that allows or denies access to
the bucket based on what's mentioned in
the policy so bucket policy is really an
ion policy we can allow and deny
permission to an s3 resource with bucket
policy we can also define security rules
that apply to more than one file in a
bucket now in this case you know we can
create an user or let's say there's
already a user called simply learn or we
can allow or deny that user connection
to the s3 bucket or connecting to the s3
bucket using bucket policy and bucket
policies are written in JSON script and
let's see how that's done all right
there are tools available for us to help
us create bucket policies what you're
looking at is a tool available online
that helps us to create a bucket policy
so let's use this tool to create a
bucket policy I'm gonna create a denies
statement I'm gonna deny all actions to
the s3 bucket and what is the AR n2
which we want to attach the AR end of
the resources actually the name of the
bucket but it really expects us to give
that key in a different format so the AR
n is available right here coffee bucket
AR n so this is actually gonna deny
everybody now we wanted to deny a user
just one user now look at that now we
have a policy that has been created
that's denying access to the bucket and
it's denying a user called simply lon
pretty much done so I can use the policy
and go over to bucket policies to want
to save it only the user called simply
learn won't have access to the bucket
and the rest of them will have access to
it so once I save it it gets added and
only the user simply learn will not have
access to the bucket because we deny
them purposefully the other features of
s3 include data protection we can
protect our data in s3 with now one of
which is bucket policy I can also use
encryption to protect my data I can also
use AM policy to protect my data so
Amazon s3 provides a durable
storage not only that it also gives us
unprotected and scalable infrastructure
needed for any of our object storage
requirements so here the data is
protected by two means one is data
encryption and the other one is data
worsening data encryption is encrypting
the data so others won't get access or
even if they get access to the file they
won't be able to access the data without
the encryption key and versioning is
making multiple copies of the data so
let's talk about them in detail
what's data encryption now data
encryption refers to protecting the data
while it is being transmitted and
protecting the data while it is at rest
now data encryption can happen in two
ways one is client encryption encryption
at rest and server-side encryption
encryption that's in motion client-side
encryption refers to when client sends
the data they encrypt the data and send
it across to Amazon and server-side
encryption is when the data is being
transferred they get encrypted and stay
encrypted throughout the transfer
versioning is another security feature
let I mean it helps us so our
unintentional edits are not actually
corrupting the data for example let's
say you edited the data and now you
realize that the data is incorrect and
you want it all back now how do you roll
back without worsening it's not possible
in other words only with the worsening
it's possible so worsening it can be
utilized to preserve recovery and
restore any early versions of every
object that we stored in our Amazon s3
bucket unintentional erases or overrides
of the object can be easily regained if
we have versioning enabled and it's
possible only if we have one file with
the same team name and any time we
update the file
it keeps the file name but creates a
different version ID take this bucket
and data for example you know photo dot
PMG is a file that was initially stored
it attached a version ID to it and then
we edited it let's say we added some
watermark we you know added some graphic
do it and that's now the new version of
it when we store it we store it with the
same filename it accepts the same
filename but creates a new version ID
and attaches it anytime we want rollback
we can always go to the console look at
the old versions pick the version ID and
roll back to the old version ID alright
let's take this example now I'm in a
bucket that we've been using for a while
and let me upload an object now before
we actually upload an object this bucket
needs to be versioning enabled so let me
wash and enable this bucket from this
point onwards this bucket is gonna
accept versioning
so let me upload an object photo dot
JPEG let me upload it alright it
successfully got uploaded good enough
it's uploaded now let me upload another
object with the same file name now look
at that it was uploaded at 7:40 35 a.m.
let me upload it another object with the
same file name that I have it stored
right here that got up to uploaded but
with the same name alright so that's the
other photo now what if I want to switch
back the way I would switch back is
simply switch back to the older version
look at that this is the latest version
and this is the old version that I have
I can simply switch back to the old
version that was created at
such-and-such time and I can open it
that's gonna open the old file so in
short it creates different version of
the data that I create as long as it's
with the same name and at any point I
can go and roll back to the original
data this is a very good use case if you
want to use s3 for storing our codes
let's talk about other feature like
cross region replication now cross
region replication is an very cool
feature if you want to automatically
keep a copy of the data in a totally
different region for you know data
durability for any additional data
durability
or if you want to serve data to your
customers who live in another country or
who are accessing your data from another
country if you want to serve the data
with low latency cross region
replication is a very cool feature that
you can use and get benefited from and
let's see how that's done so before we
actually do a lab on cross region
replication let's put together a proper
definition for it
cross region replication is a feature
that provides automatic copying of every
object uploaded to our bucket or your
bucket sauce bucket and it automatically
copies the data to the destination
bucket which is in a different AWS
region as you see here in the picture I
put data only in region 1 it's gonna
copy the data to region 2 and for us to
use cross region replication versioning
must be done on so it creates versions
and copies to versions as well if
tomorrow
the original region goes down let's say
the other region will be active and it
has the complete data that was present
in the original region or at any point
if we want to simply you know cut the
region replication and use the other
bucket as in standalone bucket it can be
used as well because it already has all
the data that was present in the master
or all the data that was present in the
original replication bucket let's see
how that stops so there are two things
needed one is worsening and another one
is a sole when we transfer data from a
one bucket to another bucket we need
proper permissions to do so and these
roles they give us proper permissions to
transfer data from one bucket to another
bucket let's see how that's done right
so here's my bucket a bucket and US are
again let's create another bucket in
Mumbai
call it dot Mumbai dot-com and put it in
put it in Mumbai or create that bucket
in Mumbai they go we have one in Oregon
we have one in Mumbai we're planning to
replicate or create application between
these two right create application
between these two buckets so go to the
first bucket go to management and start
our application add a rule so all
content in this bucket is gonna get
replicated this is my source bucket it's
quite simple select the destination
bucket add my destination bucket is
gonna be simply lon
Samuel dot Mumbai com all right it says
well you have versioning enabled in your
sauce bucket but not on your destination
bucket do you want enable it now without
which we won't be able to proceed
further so let's go ahead and enable
worsening through the console that shows
up and then like I said it's gonna
require permission to put data on to the
other bucket now I can create different
roles these are different roles that are
used for different other services I can
also choose to create a role that
specifically gives permission only to
move the data from one bucket to another
bucket three months it's done so if I go
over to my source bucket and if I add
some data to it let's say index dot HTML
assuming I'm adding some files to it in
theory they should move to the other
region automatically they go I'm in the
mumbai region and the data they got
moved to the other region automatically
let's talk about the other feature
called transfer acceleration now it's a
very handy and a helpful tool or a
service to use if we are transferring
data which is very long distance from us
meaning from the client to the s3 bucket
let's say from my local machine which is
in India if I transfer the data over to
Oregon let's say it's a long distance it
fit is gonna go to the internet it's
gonna go through high latency
connections and my transfer might get
delayed if it is an one gigabyte file
it's
okay but if we're talking about anything
that's you know five terabytes sighs you
know if you're talking about anything
that's a five terabyte in size then it's
not gonna be a pleasant experience so in
those cases I can use transfer
accelerator with which in a secure way
but in a fast way or a fastest way
transfers my data from the laptop or
from client to the s3 bucket and it
makes use of a service called cloud
front to transfer or to enable the data
acceleration so the way it would do it
is instead of copying the data directly
to the location instead of copying the
data directly to the destination bucket
it copies the data locally into a cloud
front location which is available very
local to whatever place we are in and
from there it copies the data directly
to an s3 bucket not going through the
internet it helps eliminate a lot of
latency that could get added when
transferring the data so let's see how
that's done right here I'm in the s3
bucket and under properties I can find
transfer accelerator and if I enable
transfer accelerator so I'm in another
bucket let me go to properties and then
we go to transfer accelerator and enable
transfer accelerator so now if I put
data into this bucket they're gonna get
copied to the local cloud front location
and from there they're gonna get copied
to the s3 bucket from the cloud front
now if I need to compare you know how
the speed is gonna be compared to
directly putting the data to the
internet and using cloud front there is
a tool available that actually runs for
a while and then comes with a report
that tells me how much will be the
improved speed if I use transfer
accelerator and it shows for all the
regions available in Amazon so from the
source to the destination if you want to
put you know what's the normal and
what's the accelerated speed when you
transfer the data those results we will
get in this screen so at the moment this
tool is going through testing like
uploading some file through the internet
and uploading some file using cloud
front
it has come up with the calculation that
if I'm uploading file to San Francisco
compared to uploading through the
internet and through cloud front it's 13
times faster so similar way it's gonna
calculate for all the regions available
and it's gonna give me a result
all right let's summarize what did we
learn we started a learning with the
types of storage is available in the
cloud like s3 EFS EBS glacier Storage
Gateway snowball and two types of
snowballs available and then we
gradually started to discuss about what
is s3 and then the benefits of s3 the
durability the cost
scalability the availability the
security and the flexibility and they
different the simple ways of data
transfer that s3 offers and then we did
couple of labs about beating a bucket
creating cross region replication
creating a bucket policy things like
that and then we discussed a lot of
features that s3 provides like
restricting access versioning things
like that and then we discussed a few
features of s3 like worsening are
creating a bucket policy how do I secure
a data in s3 I believe you really
enjoyed this session we will meet again
in another similar session like this
thank you
bye for now
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here